[Musique]
bonjour Bienvenue chez les econoclast
nous avons le plaisir de vous présenter
un nouveau groupe de réflexion
multidisciplinaire dans l'objectif sera
simple vous donner des arguments clairs
limpides et que vous ne pourrez pas
retrouver dans le mainstream afin que
vous puissiez vous construire des
scénarios et être en mesure en capacité
de mieux décryp décrypter l'actualité
économique qui nous entour nous avons
souhaité nous réunir au sein de ce sy
tank de façon à démocratiser l'accès à
l'information économique et géopolitique
de permettre au public d'avoir accès à
une information donné sans parti prix
idéologique sans biais avec intégrité de
façon à ce que chacun puisse faire sa
propre opinion nous allons travailler
sur quatre principaux axes le premier
c'est la démocratisation des concepts
économiques c'est mettre en lumière
certains paradoxes sur lequel la plupart
des analystes passent allègrement et
qu'il faut mettre en lumière et qu'il
faut essayer de confronter à des
réalités qui souvent ne sont pas celle
qu'on vous présente la deuxième chose
c'est la c'est l'analyse financière
l'analyse financière et économique et
macro-économique et géopolitique et
politique et essayer de vous donner une
autre vision des choses la 3è c'est la
prospective c'est-à-dire mettre en place
un certain nombre de scénaris qui vous
permettront d'anticiper les choses un
petit peu mieux que maintenant et la 4è
ce sont les solutions on va essayer de
trouver ensemble des solutions pour
défendre vos patrimoines pour vous
expliquer comment vivre dans le monde
qui nous attend donc vous l'avez compris
nous avons décidé euh de réfléchir
sérieusement mais en nous interdisant de
verser dans l'esprit de sérieux et de
dispenser des vérités révélées nous
notre crédo c'est l'expérience de
terrain nous avons eu les uns les autres
la chance de de beaucoup voyager de nous
immerger dans des réalités économiques
et géopolitique très
hétérogène nous en avons remonté des
expériences que nous avons confronté
nous en sommes parvenus à des
conclusions souvent déconcertante c'est
cela que nous espérons partager avec
vous mais partage ça veut dire aussi
accueillir de nouveaux profils de
nouvelles compétences en d'autres termes
les éconoclastes s'enrichisse de
différence retrouvez-nous sur
[Musique]
lesconoclast.fr